all right this next story
at first i wasn't going to cover it at
all
the story is that at an atlanta braves
game over the weekend at the world
series
um donald trump participated in the
tomahawk chop now the tomahawk chop is
this sort of ritual or routine or you
know i don't know what you want to call
it
that is done at the atlanta braves
baseball games it also has been done
elsewhere the exeter chiefs
used the tomahawk chop but it's it's
quite well known for
the atlanta braves and the idea is that
it's sort of a chopping motion done with
your hand as if you're holding an axe
it's a reference to uh scalping by
native americans and what's problematic
about it you know every time sometimes
it's like people play really dumb they
go what what's xenophobic or what's what
you know you i don't know whether the
right word is right word is xenophobic
or racist or whatever
but you're essentially um portraying as
savages
native american peoples in the united
states and
of course the more we learn about native
populations the more we learn that there
was quite a lot here they had complex
societies they were developing uh uh
technology you know it's
it it's just a historical but it's also
just really kind of vile and the story
that first started floating around was
oh trump does the tomahawk chop and it's
like yeah whatever trump's an idiot i'm
not going to cover it but then the
storyline became that during that
melania trump appears to turn away and
look disgusted and kind of roll her eyes
at trump as all of this is going on and
it's again this whole thing of oh
melania's being held captive melania
really hates trump and all of this sort
of thing for me the real story is that
they were both there doing the tomahawk
chop so let's start with the first video
this is the tomahawk chop taking place
and both melania and trump are doing it
if you can't see it
you're not missing that much it's trump
and melania doing the tomahawk chop take
a look
[Music]
okay so it's cringy it's just it's just
gross like it
it's just what what the hell is the
former president doing it's crazy that
this is even done
that's for me the real story that trump
participated in that that was a blip but
then the big story became this moment
that i'm playing for you here on repeat
where melania smiles and this was either
you know right before right after the
tomahawk chop and she then just kind of
grimaces and rolls her eyes and turns
away and it's again this whole thing of
melania doesn't like donald trump
is she safe is she being held hostage if
she's really that disgusted with trump
she certainly hasn't shown disgust
with the specific ideas and xenophobia
and backwards thinking that trump
promulgated and emulated during his
presidency she would show up and talk
about a lot of the same things that
donald trump did when in her rare public
appearances there would be some
occasional little
apparent disagreement but for me the
story here
is not oh melania's disgusted again and
maybe she hates trump maybe she is and
maybe that's true but she's not acted on
it in any real way for me the real story
is the fact that the president and the
the former president and the former
first lady
are doing the tomahawk chop
at a uh baseball game which is just a
horrible horrible
um
again just like a portrayal of of
unilateral savage savagery from the very
native populations that were decimated
um by the arriving settlers of what is
now the united states so it's like the
prototypical example of the real story
being being missed as uh
what was happening was was horrifying um
just from yahoo news melania trump
attended a world series baseball game
cameras showed her quick pivot from
smiling with her husband to turning away
and rolling her eyes twitter also caught
the moment igniting discussion on the
platform melania trump strikes again
it's pretty pathetic her her strikes
have been
um
superficial in nature and meaningless in
substance and that's really the story
here so if you disagree if you think
that it that her reaction really is the
big story versus the fact that they were
both participating in the tomahawk chop
uh let me know let me know i i'm open to
being convinced but for me the real
story is the tomahawk chop one of our
sponsors today is bluechu a unique
online service delivering the same
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
in a chewable form and at a fraction of
the cost and they're giving my audience
an entire month supply for free so if
you think you could benefit from an
extra boost of confidence
when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discreet package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of blue chews tablets are made in
the usa the entire process is just a few
clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping